[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui j'ai la grande chance et le
grand plaisir de recevoir un journaliste
un grand reporter qui travaille pour TF1
et qui vient nous faire part de son
expérience notamment en Ukraine il est
yvelinois bien évidemment
Axel charmessens bonjour Véronique merci
d'être là
c'est gentil je sais que vous avez très
peu de temps vous êtes toujours en
voyage la plupart du temps et voilà on a
réussi à vous capter et c'est super bon
alors nous aussi moi j'aimerais donc on
a dit que vous étiez vlinois vous avez
passé une bonne partie de votre enfance
à Versailles et puis vous êtes resté un
peu dans la région avant de vous envoler
par Mons et pavot car tel est votre ADN
si j'ai bien compris
pourquoi avoir choisi ce métier de
journaliste qu'on reporter alors j'ai
choisi ce métier parce que quand j'étais
plus jeune
je faisais beaucoup de sport beaucoup de
sport dit à l'époque un petit peu
extrême et c'était des sports qui
assez cher donc je me suis dit qu'il
fallait que je trouve un métier qui me
permette de les accomplir et surtout de
voyager un petit peu partout dans le
monde de rencontrer tous les plus grands
sportifs tous les gens qui qui me
faisaient rêver à cette époque-là et je
me suis dit que finalement
caméraman c'était le poste idéal parce
que c'était la personne qui allait
monter dans l'hélico qui allait plonger
sous l'eau qui allait grimper au plus
près du champion voilà c'était ça
c'était ça ma motivation à l'époque
d'accord et du coup vous avez donc
réalisé tout un nombre de sujets depuis
depuis quelques années déjà des choses
toujours un peu extrême alors qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui était le plus fort
pour vous vous avez des souvenirs de
grandes trouilles de grande angoisse
surtout de voyages et de passion et puis
de belles rencontres parce que c'est
surtout ça aussi qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
je continue à se faire ce métier et
surtout aller sur le terrain parce que
les plus beaux reportages c'est pas
forcément ceux qui sont plus loin
et plus spectaculaires c'est surtout les
plus belles rencontres avec les gens
donc ça peut être et rencontres humaines
donc ça peut se passer
dans les Yvelines par exemple
mais voilà c'est ça le but c'est de
rencontrer des gens raconter des
histoires et puis créer des amitiés
parce que je suis resté en contact
évidemment avec beaucoup de personnes
que j'ai filmées alors c'est sujet vous
les vendiez à des chaînes vous avez
travaillé pour qui du coup vous étiez
indépendant alors j'ai commencé en
poussant les portes en fait pour rentrer
à la télé et en leur demandant de en
leur disant que voilà il fallait
absolument prendre parce que voilà dans
ce domaine là j'avais beaucoup de
contacts donc c'est ça qui a fait que je
suis rentré au début à la 5
alors pas France 5 d'aujourd'hui mais la
5 degrés à l'époque et puis rapidement
j'ai quand même fait un stage de trois
mois pour devenir journaliste reporter
d'image donc journaliste caméraman
et j'ai commencé à proposer des
reportages dans les domaines de
prédilection
le parachutisme l'implantisme le ski etc
et à partir de là j'ai travaillé pour
une émission d'aventure pendant trois
ans sur France 3 qui s'appelle qui
s'appelait zigzag le magazine de
l'aventure est en pleine époque où je
suis Aya d'accord par la suite j'ai
continué à faire des sujets pour
l'émission où soya
et puis après du grand reportage pour
une émission qui s'appelait 52 sur La
Une TF1 reportage ou des émissions comme
ça et très rapidement TF1 mais nous
avait demandé avec mon cousin de créer
une société de production
Patrick Charles messans
et on a créé des une société de
production et donc on est devenu
producteur et ça change quoi ça alors
pas grand chose si ce n'est qu'on est
libre de faire un petit peu ce qu'on
veut OK et de proposer à aux chaînes
qu'on aime bien aux émissions qu'on aime
bien les reportages qui
vont déjà tout filmé tout ça oui c'est
pas eux qui finance pour y aller alors
si c'est eux qui financent le reportage
donc avant de partir on va les
rencontrer on leur propose notre partage
eux-mêmes peuvent apporter évidemment
des remarques et des idées on est
toujours meilleur à plusieurs et après
on part faire notre reportage et
ce qu'ils veulent vous y allez après
ça peut changer en route par un requin
ça ne vous ai pas arrivé pourtant vous
les avez bien bien côtoyés alors c'est
une passion pour vous une vraie passion
et j'ai plongé un peu partout dans le
monde en faisant des reportages sur les
requins baleines un bouledogue tigre
citron etc
mais il y a pas que ça il y a aussi
enfin toutes les autres
aussi bien en montagne pôle Nord pôle
Sud Amazonie voilà c'était des dieux qui
me faisaient rêver jeune donc j'ai
toujours essayé de trouver
quelqu'un qui pourrait m'emmener sur
place et pouvoir raconter des histoires
vous avez le pays le monde est si vaste
par exemple je suis jamais allé au Japon
et j'aimerais bien aller au Japon je
connais pas sa matière voilà mais il y a
plein d'autres pays évidemment que j'ai
pas que je connais pas alors tous ces
reportages puis finalement d'autres sont
arrivés d'autres plus comment dire sur
sur des conflits de mon entier et c'est
devenu un petit peu votre cap de visite
pendant un certain temps si je comprends
bien
parce qu'en fait j'aime faire tout type
de reportage et même très jeune j'ai
commencé à j'ai mes premiers reportages
sur des terrains chauds c'était
à Sarajevo voilà donc là j'étais déjà
quelques années après j'ai fait le
Rwanda des pays le Burundi RDC enfin
différents pays sous tension comme ça
les Intifada en Israël
et puis après plein de reportages qui
sont pas forcément des guerres mais qui
sont des endroits très tendus comme des
trafics de drogue en Amérique du Sud ou
là on est au contact en fait des
trafiquants on travaille aussi avec la
police donc c'est souvent un petit peu
compliqué mais tendu mais intéressant
voilà vous avez toujours vous avez eu
très peur parfois
alors peur oui oui on a peur quelquefois
mais on est toujours sous tension donc
ça va et puis on essaye toujours
évidemment de prendre tous les
paramètres et de faire attention à ça et
à partir du moment où on est paramètres
si on a un qui est orange et pas vert
mais faut savoir dire non quoi il faut
savoir pas y aller c'est pas facile
parce qu'on peut se mettre une pression
par rapport à la rédaction
mais en même temps c'est parce qu'il
nous disent ils nous disent au contraire
si jamais
il y aura pas de sujet ce soir mais au
moins ce sera en vie ok donc fort de
cette expérience sur des lieux de
conflits
c'est TF1 récemment qui est venu vous
chercher voilà donc là on ouvre une
nouvelle page on ouvre une nouvelle page
début de la guerre donc en février
j'avais envie d'y aller parce qu'en fait
couvrir des événements historiques c'est
extra manière pour moi d'ouvrir des
choses qui seront dans les livres
d'histoire demain c'est quand même
génial de l'action
c'est quand même quelque chose de moi
qui me qui m'intéresse qui me fascine et
puis TF1 m'a appelé parce que
c'est une guerre assez dure avec une
vraie armée en face donc ça tape dur
parce que il y a des armes lourdes
donc rapidement ils ont cherché des gens
à l'extérieur parce que même en interne
c'était parfois compliqué certains
pouvaient y aller une fois
pouvait au retour avoir une pression de
la famille qui s'inquiète et voilà parce
que c'est très difficile en fait souvent
pour les gens qui restent et plus facile
pour nous c'est facile de partir dans
l'action mais c'est très dur d'attendre
quelqu'un qui est parti donc c'est donc
voilà et puis surtout il cherchait des
gens
expérimentés à guéri à ce type de
terrain
et ils m'ont proposé et j'ai dit j'ai
tout de suite dit oui alors votre équipe
elle est elle est constituée de combien
de personnes alors on part en général à
deux ou à trois donc un jour on essaie
rédacteur un journaliste reporter
d'image quelques fois deux et puis sur
place on retrouve un fixeur donc c'est
quelqu'un de local qui a pas forcément
une expérience va en général qui n'a
aucune expérience dans ce genre de
milieu parce que la guerre est arrivée
et pour la plupart j'avais jamais vécu
ça par ceux qui avaient vécu en 2014 la
première le premier épisode
et on se retrouve donc à trois ou quatre
sur le terrain voilà d'accord et là vous
partez avec une mission bien précise on
vous dit tu vas aller étudier tel
problème ou pas ou quelle est la place
de l'imprévu
en sachant ou dans quelle région on va
aller c'est bon concrètement alors on
passe soit par la Pologne soit par la
Moldavie en avion et après en voiture on
passe la frontière à pied et de l'autre
côté de la frontière notre fixeur vient
nous chercher en voiture et on traverse
le pays pour aller jusqu'à jusqu'à l'est
où on doit aller au sud au nord en
fonction de l'actualité en fait et là
une fois là-bas
on vous a déterminé une mission précise
on va dans les endroits où je passe un
petit peu l'actualité
donc on se rapproche en général
évidemment de la ligne de front
en prenant plein de précautions alors
déjà on est accrédité par le
gouvernement ukrainien on a des cartes
de presse ukrainienne
un pays avec des checkpoints un peu
partout évidemment des contrôles en
permanence
qui se densifie plus on approche de la
ligne de front et là sans carte de
presse évidemment on ne passe pas en
fait voilà les militaires nous bloquent
donc nous on est autorisé à passer et
puis plus on avance plus on s'approche
ben nous on prend des renseignements on
demande aux militaires qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
la veille la nuit le matin même en
fonction de l'heure à laquelle on arrive
et les militaires nous renseignent en
disant surtout ne prenez pas cette route
parce que là elle est pilonnée en ce
moment donc passée par tel village etc
on télécharge aussi sur nos téléphones
avant parce qu'il y a plus de réseau sur
l'île de front donc on télécharge tout
sur nos téléphones on étudie le terrain
avant il y a quand même un petit
préparation à chaque fois qu'on y va on
se donne un cap
s'il y a moins de doute sur quoi que ce
soit on fait demi-tour
et bah des obus qui tombent trop proche
de nous alors qu'on pensait que cette
route était plus safe et ben on fait
demi-tour parce qu'évidemment la
situation évolue d'heure en heure donc
ça va très vite c'est tous un réseau
pour vous prévenir sans réseau alors on
a des téléphones satellites avec nous on
a tous un système de sécurité avec TF1
on peut être déclenché une balise à tout
moment
[Musique]
dans leur base man dans les handicaps il
se protège comme ça et puis j'espère que
ça va passer et je suppose que d'autres
en fait restent alors ce qui est plus
étrange parce qu'on voit souvent des
familles avec des enfants donc on leur
demande pourquoi il reste et nous disent
bah voilà je sais pas où aller mais on
peut supposer quand même pour certains
qui sont plus pro russe
ou certains ont de la famille en Russie
forcément donc dans les parties qui ont
été occupées en 2014 ils ont des ils ont
de la famille là-bas donc ils ont ils
sont pro russe donc finalement ils se
disent bah nous on préfère peut-être
attendre que les russes arrivent et
comme ça on pourra nous revoir notre
famille qui est de notre côté quoi voilà
c'est pas simple comme contexte alors
vous avez fait moi j'ai vu un portrait
de vous vous aviez que vous avez réalisé
sur que j'ai vu sur Instagram c'était
une jeune femme c'est un portrait très
très touchant alors j'espère qu'on aura
des images on verra c'est une jeune
femme qui joue de la flûte alors elle
est sous un sous un tunnel ou un pont on
entend les bombardements et elle on la
voit en train de
le vernis un peu écaillé enfin elle joue
cette espèce d'air lancinant c'est très
poignant on a l'impression qu'elle se
dit tant qu'il y aura les bons moi
j'arrêterai pas de jouer de la flûte et
le premier qui s'arrête à perdu quoi
c'est exactement ça en fait on arrivait
à baroute une fois de plus parce qu'en
fait on y allait tous les jours la ville
commençait à se refermer de bombarder de
plus en plus il commence à avoir des des
combats larmes automatiques dans dans le
centre-ville et
en arrivant par une petite route la
seule route d'accès qui n'était pas
bombardée
on est tombé sur un petit marché et au
bout du marché à Carrefour il y avait
cette femme qui jouait de la flûte toute
seule on s'est approché on lui a parlé
et en fait elle joue tous les matins et
pour elle c'est une façon de
voilà exactement ça voilà
c'est le lendemain elle était encore au
même Carrefour en général entre 10h et
11 heures du matin
je sais pas ce qu'elle est devenue
aujourd'hui
je suis rentré du crânien moi je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé pour elle la
ville est sous pression encore plus
aujourd'hui alors moi je vous propose de
regarder un autre portrait de femme
alors qui est complètement l'opposé elle
s'appelle fgna Emerald c'est une
guerrière une sniper sniper sniper
ukrainienne vous l'avez rencontré
comment alors on l'a rencontré on l'a
rencontré chez elle à Kiev parce qu'elle
est enceinte qu'elle ne va plus sur le
front aujourd'hui
mais c'est un article dans un journal
local d'accord Kiev qui a parlé d'elle
et notre fixeur nous a dit ah tiens
regarde c'est drôle on dirait une
héroïne presque de bande dessinée c'est
une image incroyable elle a aujourd'hui
elle joue là-dessus évidemment parce que
parce qu'il faut communiquer il faut
qu'elle puisse aider toutes les femmes
qui sont sur le front c'est devenu son
combat aujourd'hui
donc évidemment elle communique
énormément elle est très présente sur
les réseaux sociaux surtout les réseaux
sociaux et puis surtout elle a permis de
avec une association de créer des petits
kits qu'on envoie à toutes ces femmes
qui sont sur le fond il y a 5 fils 5000
femmes aujourd'hui vous demandez oui il
y en a beaucoup 5000 femmes sur le front
sur la Ligue de France qui combattent
c'est à dire qu'elles ont les armes à la
main c'est rare ça d'habitude les femmes
elles restent en retrait mais
aujourd'hui il y en a plein on en a
rencontré plein et il y a énormément de
couples qui se sont créés
on voit qu'elle se marie exactement
elle-même c'est marié sur la ligne de
front et puis j'ai pu rencontrer plein
d'autres qui sont en couple alors
certains sont sur les l'artillerie
d'autres ont tireur d'élite
d'autres combattantes il y a un peu de
tout mais beaucoup de femmes sont
présentes et voilà c'est son combat
aujourd'hui d'accord et
du coup donc elle leur propose un kit de
un peu bien-être entre guillemets pour
pouvoir vivre sur cette ligne de
une censure est-ce qu'on vous dit
sativement pas alors non on n'a pas de
censure et puis une fois sur le terrain
en fait c'est ça qui est bien c'est
qu'on a une rédaction à Paris évidemment
qui nous suit au quotidien qu'on appelle
à tout moment évidemment qu'on prévient
de tout ce qu'on va faire ça c'est
indispensable on leur dit que demain on
va on leur donne les horaires de départ
nos horaires de retour qu'on va pas être
joignable de telle heure à telle heure
et de toute façon on a un téléphone
satellite avec nous et puis des balises
de détresse
quelque chose de grave et puis encore
une fois on a on est libre de de
proposer des sujets
qu'on ressent sur place et qui nous
paraissent intéressant sur place
mais on a une entière liberté là-dessus
heureusement
oui donc toute façon vous connaissez la
ligne éditoriale vous savez ce qui va
aussi intéresser
bien sûr alors ce qui est bien aussi
c'est que donc on travaille pour TF1
mais on travaille aussi pour LCI la
chaîne la chaîne d'information de TF1 et
qui s'est consacré depuis le début de
l'invasion russe en Ukraine qui s'est
consacré qui remplit aujourd'hui à peu
près 70 à 80% de l'antenne par de
l'Ukraine donc ils sont évidemment
énormément demandeurs de contenu sur
place ou bien de direct et mettre sujet
donc très souvent on travaille pour les
deux chaînes et un sujet qu'on envoie
pour TF1 évidemment on va passer aussi
pour LCI quelquefois dans des versions
un peu plus longues voilà donc et je me
demandais une fois passé 15 jours en
Ukraine le retour en France à Paris
vous vous sentez complètement déconnecté
vous
le plus difficile en fait on passe trois
semaines un mois à chaque fois sur place
et ce qui est difficile c'est de laisser
notre fixeur en fait voilà parce que
nous on a
on travaille avec un certain nombre de
fixeurs avec les équipes ce sont des
gens qu'on connaît bien maintenant
évidemment c'est très important parce
que eux-mêmes ne travaillaient pas
forcément pour la télévision avant donc
quelque part il a fallu dans un premier
temps qui comprennent nos attentes voilà
et puis souvent ce qui est difficile
avec
des fixeurs Ukrainiens c'est que ils
sont quand même agressés eux-mêmes et
quelquefois certains nous dire
maintenant mais ça on peut pas faire ça
on peut pas faire ci et nous alors c'est
il faut le faire parce qu'il faut qu'on
monte par exemple et ben certains
moments il voulait peut-être pas qu'on
montre
alors qu'on avait l'autorisation des
positions ukrainiennes ou dire que
aujourd'hui des soldats ont pris telle
ville parce que pour eux
ouais c'est ça parce que veulent
protéger leur pays en fait et c'est très
compliqué et nous évidemment
ils ont peur de ça en fait évidemment on
le fait avec un intelligence et on pèse
évidemment le poids de chaque image il y
a certaines images confine évidemment
qu'on met pas dedans parce qu'elle
pourrait compromettre la sécurité des
gens qu'on a filmé etc souvent on a
évidemment on a des positions exactes de
l'artillerie des endroits où la nuit
peuvent cacher les les chars parce qu'il
faut les réparer donc évidemment nous on
a ces positions donc on il faut faire
très attention dans ce qu'on filme
jamais filmé l'extérieur d'un hangar ou
dans lequel
ça c'est notre responsabilité après donc
c'est important et vous fixeur ça va
vous les vous les avez tous aujourd'hui
à Paris après parce qu'ils ont ils sont
enfermés aujourd'hui dans leur pays et
d'une chose c'est de venir déjà à TF1
voir un petit peu la chaîne pour qu'il
travaille en fait ok bah écoutez encore
des millions de choses à dire Axel je
suis en essence un grand grand merci
c'était passionnant merci de m'avoir
invité et bah très bientôt au moins sur
sur les écrans en attendant merci Axel à
bientôt au revoir à tous merci de nous
avoir suivi à très vite
[Musique]